[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career
you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm ramsey personality george
campbell host of the fine print and
entree leadership podcast joined today
by none other than dr john deloney
best-selling author host of the aptly
named dr john deloney show and we're
excited to take your calls america it's
a free call today and every day triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we can talk about money relationships
emotional wellness mental health most of
that i'm going to delegate to john no i
want to watch you answer this question
john you want to watch the world burn
man come on that would make me happy
well uh i'll answer mutual fun questions
and you answer
relationships and you know what that is
that creates mutual fun
all right i wish if there was a band
he'd do the little drone we just sell
out there we only had 11 listeners and
we just lost half of them we just lost
they're like you know we're leaving well
for those that are still with us we are
so glad you're here and we have a
really a
a lobby crowd that i think is electric
today the lobby crowd is riveting i wish
you could be here to see in america the
building's on fire come visit us there
they are if you're watching uh you can
see them they're waving nicely at the
cameras so we're taking your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and we're going to kick this hour
off with dave in lansing michigan dave
welcome to the ramsay show
i thank you i appreciate you taking my
call
in a nutshell my mother is 98 years old
just recently her health decline is
declining rapidly so we put her into
assisted living which is about eight
thousand dollars a month
now she has approximately a hundred
sixty thousand dollars cash in a bank
and she has just over a million dollars
of investments
nothing crazy uh being it from the
generation that she's at so it's just
stocks and bonds
now would it be better to
to run out the money from the bank first
or take the money from the stock market
or from her investment with the fear
that the stock market might crash or go
down significantly
that's a great question dave and it does
uh bring me some joy that she has done
well financially i mean usually you get
these kinds of calls john and they're
like we have zero dollars in the bank
she's broke but she's in a good spot and
so i wouldn't worry about this the stock
market crashing but i would say she's
98. now is the time like you invested
all this money so that later you can use
this in retirement and so i don't think
there's anything wrong with using that
investment money if you want to start
with the cash that's fine you've got a
big pile of money there uh obviously
leave at least an emergency fund there
it sounds like in assisted living though
all that's all of her expenses 8
thousand a month all in
yeah yes yeah okay is that the only
place in town or is that
that seems uh
pretty high from the ones i've looked at
recently
uh no uh that seems to be going rate
there's a little bit less uh but uh
you know i guess that's the style of
living that she uh was hoping to have at
this time in her life yeah she got a
million dollars in the bank i mean in
investments in the bank so yeah she's
earned that to write out that that last
time there
um yeah i'm fully on board with george
there man i i'm thinking if it's me
i i think i would
i are you is the will all done so this
money that's in
her savings would be dispersed on when
she passes and and everyone knows where
it's going okay yeah all of a sudden yes
yeah i think i was an interesting thing
she she's never had a financial
planner you know there's somebody at the
bank that said yep we'll help you along
and they obviously have done well but
you know they lived uh very prudent they
uh
didn't have boats and uh cottages so
yeah that's that's that's
that's the joke here internally that
dave says all the time is
i'm not telling anybody anything my
grandmother didn't tell me right that's
how they lived they had this awesome
thing called common sense and another
awesome thing called math that they
could do and they continue to do it
right you end up with a million bucks in
the bank i would probably start with a
cash just for ease um until you can sit
on the financial planner and begin to
see which one of these things you could
liquidate
um and in what order is there any um
any of this stuff have to be withdrawn
that i don't you know this is first
retirement
okay and you're saying there is no
financial planner in the picture
currently
there's no advisor no
i would i would work with one to make
sure that we make the best use of this
money for the remainder of her life i
mean right now you'd be okay with a
million dollars and we're talking under
100k a year all in for
her care it would take i mean she'd have
to live another 10 years to get close to
draining the investment account
which i mean there's she could live to
108. that's that's happening i mean she
sounds like a she's she's just going to
keep on going man
um but
i would say
work with a financial advisor we of
course have our smartvestor pros around
the country you can reach out to uh in
the lansing michigan area and they can
help teach you and help you understand
what the best route to go is with this
money to make the most of it to to get
the most bang for your buck here uh but
you're in a great spot there's nothing
wrong with with using a big portion of
that cash i would leave some of it
liquid but you could use it for the
first year as you try to figure out the
next steps and what the financial
advisor recommends and they may have a
different answer than we do john but
you asked for our opinion and there it
is all right well i appreciate your help
guys hey man enjoy your day just just
for the record your mom's lucky to have
you man it's awesome that you are are
able to and willing to sit and
walk through her
uh these decisions with her in the last
few years of her life um too many folks
that i run into and that i talk to have
nobody and so good for you brother
that's awesome yeah well i appreciate
that appreciate it
during my faith in humanity man
love to hear it that's encouraging john
i feel like there's a crisis going on
where you see a lot of parents they
sacrifice for their kids and now here
they are and the kids are having to take
care of the parents and this is a very
different situation that dave is in
where he's just helping mom navigate
what to do with this pile of money yeah
that's a stress much less stressful
place to be yeah and let that be the um
let that be the
light on the hill for everybody
have a million dollars in investments
and 150 000 in cash so that when your
time comes which it will
your kids are wondering what's the best
most strategic way we can do this not
how are we going to do this that's a
very different conversation totally
different conversation i love it no
stress there well john uh before we head
to this break you are uh you're crushing
the dr john deloney show i've been
tuning in and the way you've been
handling these calls especially in some
of the people's darkest moments it is
it's inspiring i'm glad you're on the
team for those that don't know what the
show is what are you doing day in and
day out that's different from the ramsay
show
uh we are man we are taking calls
not not around money we're taking calls
around um the calls we took today that
we recorded today was um
just found out my husband's cheating on
me i don't know the next steps and just
found out that my mother's gonna be
passing away and how do i tell my kids
and it's everything from parenting to
relationships to
my kid just got this mental health
diagnosis at school and we love him but
we're tired of all these programs so
what do we do next and so it is
sitting with people when they feel like
the wheels are falling off and then we
just walk through it man we have a lot
of fun we laugh james and kelly are a
lot more joyful on that show than they
are on this one and
man it's a great time together well i'm
glad you're on the team taking those
calls and it's it must be an honor to be
the first person they think to calls i'm
gonna call doctor john and get his
thoughts on that's a pretty cool place
man that's cool well we're happy to help
here today give us a call triple eight
eight two five
five this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verse
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsay personality
joined today by dr john dolone we're
taking your calls on money on life
relationships emotional wellness you
name it we'll give it a shot so we are
here for you america and on the line
right now we've got leia in sacramento
california leah welcome to the ramsay
show
hi thanks for taking my call absolutely
how can john and i help
so my husband and i have a piece of
property up in northern california near
tahoe we're listing the property for
just over three hundred thousand um it's
actually two parcels a larger one of
about an acre and a smaller one about
half an acre we just got an offer from
um like a
branch of i guess
the county offering to put
batteries on the smaller parcel and to
lease the parcel for the next 15 or 30
years for about 30 000 a year if it's 15
years we get 450 000 over the next 15 um
if not we get 900 000 over the next 30.
um we'd still be able to sell the larger
portion but we're kind of concerned
about trying to sell the smaller portion
after 15 or 30 years
if we do accept that
um so i just i don't really know
if we should just continue to list it as
one piece and try to sell it and get
kind of the lump sum
right now
or look at this option to lease the
smaller course the smaller parcel out
and get the 30 000 over the next 15 or
30 years depending on the contract okay
why are you concerned about your ability
to sell in the future
um it's
i mean it's bear land um it's near tahoe
um which is great but there's a river
that goes through it and you can't build
a certain
i guess proximity to the river and then
you also can't build a certain proximity
to the road so it just kind of makes it
a little bit more difficult i guess
it's been on the market
for about a year but we've had it for a
few years just trying to clean up the
property and clean up the the title on
the property and things like that so
when it comes to bear land i'm
always kind of concerned about the
difficulty when it comes to selling
do you guys owe on this
no we're we're in baby step seven we
don't know on anything fantastic well
that yeah that puts you in a different
spot where you now have options what is
your household income
um we make about 150 or 150 000 years
okay
and other than that what are your next
goals i mean do you guys want to get
into real estate investing because in
baby step 7 you've got lots of options
there to build wealth to give to do some
things are you guys wanting to be in the
investment real estate business long
term
um yeah that's the plan i'm a licensed
marriage and family therapist right now
and i do a lot of crisis work on the
weekends and my husband is in real
estate so i'm looking to kind of leave
the crisis work
when
my kids are a little bit older and kind
of start helping my husband more on the
real estate side
um
so that is the plan ultimately maybe in
the next couple years
um so he started with this piece of
property and
um so what i would what i would tell you
is if i could if i could secure a lease
for
what are we talking i mean
we're talking almost 9x
over 30 years your return um i would
sign that today
and sell the bigger piece
again this doesn't bear out over time
but a philosophy that i live by that i
was given by a guy when i was younger is
i invest in dirt because they stopped
making that a long time ago now you can
buy stupid plots of raw land in the
middle of southern utah i mean that are
useless
um
having a half acre plot or an acre plot
next to lake tahoe even with the
restrictions i can't imagine
you're not able to unload this even if
you sell it at a reduced cost in 30
years
you still have made a million dollars
10x what you were going to sell it for
right
okay yeah and so the beauty of your
situation now is you've got an acre to
sell that you can hold cash on and
you've got a long-term lease on dirt
that you're still going to own
in the into the future
so it to me it feels like it's not you
can't lose either way
okay yeah the way the way i'm thinking
about this is based on whatever your
next goal is which it sounds like you're
wanting to step away from the workforce
maybe uh for for what you're doing right
now and to me you don't need that 300
000 today there's no fire to put out
with selling it today getting 300 grand
so i like the idea of locking it in for
30 years and making almost a million
dollars i mean you can just invest that
money if you want and that becomes a
whole new nest egg for you guys in 30
years from now that's incredible so
because you're on baby step 7 if you
were like hey we've got a pile of debt
over here we've got to clean up i might
say hey let's sell that thing get rid of
this debt and we can restart on real
estate investing down the line but
because of where you guys are at you
have options and that's the beauty of
baby step seven you guys have done
really well
thank you way to go thank you so much
for the call
awesome all right we're going to zach in
dallas texas zach welcome to the ramsay
show
hey george and thank you for pronouncing
my name right i actually thought you
were going to misspell it yeah z-e-c-h
kelly's a great help i will say that how
you doing
doing pretty good i'm wondering if you
and dr john have some tips on how i can
help kind of coach my sister-in-law
through the
college application process without
scaring her stressing her out with all
the things that go with it what what has
put you in this coach role are you just
wanting to help her she asks for it
part of the question if you have a tip
on this i want to ask her if she will
help me with it and talk to her mom
about it as well but
it's also because like i'm pretty much
the only ramsay follower in the family
and i know like i've watched broad
future i watched your
fine print episode on the student loan
crap and
i don't want to see her go through that
i want to see her succeed on what she
wants to do because she's a very
talented girl she wants to go into
performing arts and stuff and she's
filling out some process some
applications and stuff but i'm trying to
figure out how to
like talk to her about some of this
stuff like the dangers of loans and
stuff and how to avoid those
yeah go through the process but so
here's part of the reason i'm asking for
help i'm
i'm a little too practical and i don't
know how to just
if i go into this blind i'm gonna say
something that's gonna scare her out of
listening
yes so here's an important thing i want
you to hang on to and i want you to wrap
your heart up in this okay
you cannot make her do anything
you cannot coach somebody that doesn't
want to be coached
you can only reach out and say i would
love to help
if you're willing to accept it or i'd
love to go to take you to coffee and
talk to you about the student loan
i've talked about how to apply to
colleges but you're inserting yourself
into a process you haven't been asked to
enter
and that usually ends up in messed up
relationships
and so
you're asking for an invitation to a
party you weren't invited to
and i think your heart is good and i'm
glad you're asking for that invitation i
say go for it but don't approach it with
hey y'all aren't that smart and i just
watched a documentary and i'm going to
teach you all about that i've had my
friends who are vegans do that to me
i've had my friends who are filling the
blank they watch a documentary and they
call
and uh hey we need to go talk about this
and it usually ends up in oh my gosh so
it's best to say hey i would love to
reach out to you and
i'd love to
uh if you'd be interested in this
conversation what we're going to do is
hang on the line here we're going to
send you a copy of
anthony o'neil's debt free degree that
i'm going to send it to you for free and
you can give that to her
and you can say hey i got a gift for you
i would love to sit down and talk to you
about how to apply for college how
student loans work and see if we can
come up with a solution there i want you
to not just have a lot of info about how
much student loans suck i want you to
have some info on how to actually apply
for college how to get scholarships how
to take two years of free community
college if that works in your state and
then how do you transfer that on and on
and on and on go with some information
and some data and not just a fired up
spirit yeah and i think even getting her
to maybe watch the bard future
documentary with you hey friday night
hey you want to hang out let's catch up
i've got this great documentary if you
want to watch it with me that could open
up the conversation to where maybe she's
starting to ask some questions and
that's when you can step in but the the
phrasing of it it felt like hey she
needs some coaching it's like john's
coming into me and saying george i'm
going to be a personal trainer and i was
like john i didn't know i was overweight
need to get fit well this now it's a
personal attack well i mean let's let's
be honest
who are you going to trust america when
it comes to fitness me or john but hey
that's actually a great a great a great
thought is when you walk up to someone
you look at them and you're like
you need to get in the gym i got a
workout praying for you i mean no one's
gonna listen to you after that i'm
immediately upset that's right if you
knock on somebody's door and say hey i
just have my life changed and i'd love
to share it with you are you interested
then you might get an audience that's a
different spirit but i love the heart
behind it zach we're rooting for you as
you coach her through this college
process to get her to avoid student loan
debt this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
if you aren't strapped with student loan
payments odds are you know someone who
is
millions of people are putting their
lives on hold they can't buy a house or
have kids because they're stuck or even
worse they're waiting and waiting and
waiting for the government to save them
with student loan forgiveness what a
joke
our team has produced a brand new
documentary feature film called borrowed
future and it is out now it uncovers the
dark side of the student loan industry
and exposes how the system is built to
work against you you'll see dave ramsey
and dr john deloney weigh in on the epic
failure otherwise known as the student
loan program along with featured
interviews from other industry insiders
and thought leaders like seth godin and
seth fratman we're coming at this issue
hard people we're taking big swings at
the student loan problem with the goal
to arm parents and students across the
country with the truth that you do not
have to take out loans to get a college
education you can graduate debt free and
avoid the predatory student loan
industry borrowed future is available to
watch now and you can find it on apple
tv amazon prime video google play or at
borrowed future dot com
dude i'm excited about this man so
pumped the feedback has been yeah it's
burning through man incredible
we are giving this away to teachers i
want to let america know that i didn't
know that if you are a teacher
or if you are a youth pastor you've got
you are leading teens in your life we
want to show this uh for free so you can
access this go to bardfuture.com you can
scroll down and click on the link if you
are a teacher or in that in that realm
where you are trying to influence the
next generation which is a difficult
task and so to have an 88-minute
documentary you can push play on that
says it for you yeah that is a game
changer
so i'm real excited and you did a great
job in this john really unpacking what
you've seen because you've been in the
education world for a long long time and
i love it you you loved it so much you
left well i mean i i do i believe in it
and i love it um and i think it's
important for
our country i think it's important for
individuals
and there's got to be another way
got to be another way man yeah it's not
the only path we got to reimagine doing
different student loans aren't the only
path college isn't the only path and we
are we're very pro-education yeah we
always have to caveat we love education
but you got to do it the right way and
you don't want to leave college with a
hundred thousand fifty thousand dollars
in student loan debt wondering wait i
thought this was supposed to set me up
for adulthood no i was there man we had
six figures and i remember
pacing my house at night my wife was
asleep wondering what we're gonna do
and i was still in school so they were i
mean it was like the meter was still
running you know what i mean and i
didn't i mean i that's one of the most
desperate feelings of my life not having
enough money to pay my bills the meter's
running i'm just racking them up because
i'm halfway through a program
and i don't know how we're gonna do this
like i just don't know how we're gonna
figure it out and so yeah it's there's i
i love it i'm all in on college and
universities and we gotta do it a
different way yep it's hard man check it
out borrowed future.com or apple tv
amazon prime video and google play all
right open phone lines this hour the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five bob joins us in
new brunswick new jersey bob welcome to
the ramsay show
hey thanks for having me guys i
appreciate it absolutely thank you
well um i
turned 62 years old this year
and that means that i could potentially
well i will have access to my
self-employment pension so you talk
about education i am an educator i teach
boating education as in uh drive a boat
on the water very cool and um how long
have you done that for bob
i've been doing it for a
good part of 12 13 years now very cool
man
prior to that i was self-employed as a
mobile disc jockey weddings banquet
parties all that good stuff and
prior to that worked out a
pharmaceutical company realized that i
didn't really want to work in corporate
america but anyway well the first time i
took my boat out i recognized in short
order i probably should have had some
classes on how to even do what i'm doing
he needed you bob where were you bob i'm
glad there are people like you out in
the world keeping the water safe from
people like me so what's up man i i
do i do my best at it i really do and
and and and on top of that i really
really enjoy what i do so i'm really
blessed and uh
so so the challenges that i have noticed
i didn't say problems the challenges
that i have are all first world
challenges
um i do have debt and i have money to
pay it off
i'm just looking for some common sense
uh
advice here on how to go about
doing that now again emergency fund you
know taking care of uh you know plenty
of money in the set between you know
between uh my wife's 403 b and my set
where we have plenty uh plenty that you
know to cover these
uh debts however um you know i just want
to throw these things at you we have a
mortgage
we put solar on top of our house so and
i purchased that as opposed to leasing
it
do you have a car loan and uh and my son
has a loan that uh i want to get some
advice on uh that he's working towards
becoming a commercial pilot so
um you know the loan rates could be a
little better and i think with my credit
rating i might be able to do well too so
talk to me on
what would be the best uh best way you
know
to pay these off so bob you said you
have a car loan for your own personal
debt you've got the mortgage your
personal mortgage and a car loan that's
it for you
uh the solar loan as well oh i thought
you said you purchased it outright
oh you took a loan out yes okay okay
well again purchase as opposed to leafs
oh
okay all right so you've got the solder
like the solar renewable energy credits
in new jersey they're very uh
forward-thinking and uh
for each uh
s-rack i'm i'm getting 220 put right
into my bank account so okay all right
so here's what we teach is the baby
steps of course the debt snowball and
you said you already have an emergency
fund and you have the cash to pay for it
is this cash in the retirement accounts
or is it liquid innocent
yes it is you don't have the money in a
savings account in cash to pay for it
you would have to dip into those
retirement funds at this point
that is correct
okay
what's the car loan how much on that
uh it's 23 000. and what about the solar
solar is 43 000.
that's going to take a while to to roi
on even at 200
well because i have an electric vehicle
um that actually has taken it down to uh
according to my calculations if i
included that without the electric
vehicle charging
uh my my payback is 7.67
years is that what the sales person told
you
or is that with the no no no when you
include the gas tank
i did take the 30 federal tax credit
okay
all right so the car loan is gonna go
first bob so that's what we have to
tackle first i don't know what the car
is worth uh is it worth more than 23
yeah it's a it's yeah it's a uh
it's a 2020 tesla okay oh
yeah so it's it's roughly worth uh i
paid i paid 50 000 for it so
i'm gonna say it's probably 45 000 now
okay
well
if you want to do it the ramsey way
you're going to have to line these up
from smallest to largest if i'm you i'm
right now bob truthfully i'm probably
selling the
tesla well uh household income is it
varies because of because of my business
but it's uh generally between 150 and
200.
okay so i i mean you can hang on to the
car there you got 20 left on it
23 23. so we got about 66 total in debt
that is non-mortgage bob from what i'm
hearing and with your income could you
not pay this off in the next eight
months yeah you should be done in less
than a year pay that off
the car pay off everything and do it
with your income
that makes the most sense that's you
know i could i could definitely do that
so i would love to see you and your wife
just buckle down for 10 months and pay
off the solar and pay off your car and
then knock out this mortgage how much
you get left under mortgage
uh it's uh 60k oh bob what do you mean
bob
you could be done with this whole thing
in a year
done
max two years then you're what 64.
and then you're doing some assaults out
in the street with no shirt on because
you don't want anybody any money
and then you could be like you know what
no i don't work on wednesdays just
because i don't want to how much you
have in retirement accounts
uh
well that's like i said that i we have
first world problems two and a half
million dollars oh my gosh bob i'm get i
retract this entire phone call yeah
let's go back to square one bob in fact
this is normally a free call
yeah no you're killing it dude you're
crushing it i wouldn't touch the
retirement bob you can cashflow this
whole thing and let that retirement grow
and not unplug it quite yet absolutely
yeah pay the stuff off before the year
is over and stop watching bob stop
touching debt get away from it no more
debt no more loans no more anything you
can do this man you got this you're a
baby steps millionaire we just gotta
follow the plan to a t to do it the
right way this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell ramsey personality
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast my co-host today dr
john dolone best-selling author of
redefining anxiety and host of the dr
john dolone show we're taking your calls
on pretty much everything money life
relationships mental health give us a
call triple 825-5225
the number marie joins us in cincinnati
ohio marie welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so much absolutely how can
john and i help
well um i purchased the house six years
ago for 27 000
i worked on it which i've always loved
to do and i recently sold it for uh well
actually filled it for 237 and then
after commission and
tithe and giving to my church um i have
a hundred and eighty eight thousand
way to go congratulations marie how did
you do that how many how much did you
put into it in repairs
well i did a lot of the work um
well sadly i my husband passed away
january 31st so we were doing it
together
um he's with the lord jesus it isn't
easy but it is it is um hope that you
know we will see each other so
we did it together and then um
he got
sick and then i just i've always known
how to have tool time and i've always
known how to do things um so we bought
it for 27 000 when the market was not so
hot
um
and we we put in like the things that we
couldn't repair like the roof
and the electric and the plumbing we put
in about
thirty thousand
um and so
that's how we did it wow wow
number one so we're so sorry for your
loss sounds like your husband was an
incredible guy huh
he he really was it it's um
it was difficult really really difficult
um
but
you know it's it would be harder without
jesus so
um
you know it's it's been hard it's easier
now but i mean it's only been since
january oh yeah and it's okay for it to
stay hard for a long long time yeah
we're together for a while and he sounds
like he was a great guy
and man i'm so sorry for your loss and
on the other side congratulations for
seeing this project through and
finishing it and
wow 188 000 cleared
wow so what's your whole financial
picture marie
are you okay financially obviously
you've got a big pile of money here do
you have a primary residence that you're
currently living in well i'm actually
when i sold my house like two weeks ago
uh so let's say two and a half weeks ago
i moved in with my sister who's down the
street we're super close it's just uh
she and i together
and um so my expenses went from you know
no
um
homeowners insurance or any of those
things to
my monthly expenses or like 300
i don't have a car payment i don't have
credit card debt
i don't have a school loan
i just have my monthly expenses i can
live on
nothing because that's just the way we
were raised
my parents
my parents were immigrants from
santiago chile and they taught us
how to live
with little and make money
in this beautiful america so we did what
a legacy it's awesome that's awesome so
now you're sitting here you've got no
debt and you've got a pile of cash and
you're not looking to
buy a house anytime soon because you're
living with your sister and you've got a
great situation there
right because the long-term goal is to
my i'm gonna help my sister get her
house ready and then we're gonna sell
her house and then we want to buy land
but
it's just the mar i just don't know what
to do with the money now because i'm not
going to be doing that for another year
and a half okay i don't want it sitting
in the bank doing nothing sure so it's
still a pretty short time horizon if
you're talking about a year you know 18
months from now so i wouldn't go you
know throwing it into the stock market
because of the volatility from you know
from now to 18 months from now you could
lose money so i get that you don't you
don't want to putting in a bank and it's
not going to grow by much you know in a
money market account or a good high
yield savings account you're probably
looking at about a half a percent and so
it's not super exciting to see that
money grow at such a slow pace but right
now what i want to do is protect this
money more than i do more than i want to
see it grow astronomically because of
the short time horizon now if you said
hey five years from now i want to do
this i would say all right let's put in
some good mutual funds and watch this
thing grow for five years
so a high yield savings account would be
your best bet right now for that 188 000
as you figure out what those next steps
are uh and make sure you have an
emergency fund in place do you currently
have three to six months of expenses i
know you don't have a lot of expenses
i don't i just have that's all i have is
188 000 to your name okay so i'm gonna
take six months of expenses which for
you that might be really low um but you
can park that in a savings account and
don't touch that that's just for
emergency situations that are unexpected
urgent and necessary so maybe fifteen
twenty thousand dollars you put in a
savings account yeah or in a checking
account
when you're when your transmission falls
out of your car it will be annoying not
catastrophic no stress got it got it do
you have anything in retirement do you
have a nest egg that you've been growing
i don't i um
i never worked corporate i raised my
sons you know as a stay-at-home mom and
then when my sons became men and they
didn't need me which was great um
i kind of went back to my love which is
i i'm an artist i just take vintage
things take them apart and put them back
together as julie and things like that
so my income has never been good and so
i've never had a retirement did your
husband leave you with any retirement
from his his professional career nothing
okay no and how old are you
i'm 54. okay
that actually changes the conversation
yeah the big question mark for me is how
are you going to live in retirement i
mean if you burned through this 188 in
cash and you bought some land you'd have
zero dollars to your name
um and nothing in retirement to even pay
for those expenses so that's my bigger
worry right now is that you may need to
get get a job to bring in some income to
start to build a nest egg for the next
you know decade and park that money
aside and maybe we don't start doing
investment property until we know we're
in a good place for retirement
do you have any sort of health insurance
life insurance anything like that no
yeah you may want to consider not may i
strongly recommend you
you sit down with a xander
representative and walk through what it
would look like to get some
health insurance over the next five 10
15 20 years were you able to cash flow
your husband's illness
no
you know the illness um
he was a he was
an amazing person but he and he did
construction as his career okay but
he
he died um
[Music]
it's kind of embarrassing even though
he's not here he died of
alcohol abuse okay okay and um and so
with that said you know he had his good
days and his bad days
um
and so he didn't leave anything he
didn't do anything as far as
savings or thinking of the future
that was always my job that was always
like put money aside or go get the
regular job or go do the shows that i
would do it was never
on his radar so marie here's what i want
to do we're going to give you
um a year's subscription to ramsey plus
and i want you to sit with your sister
and i want together i want you all to go
through every one of these lessons
together
everything from
a thousand dollar emergency fund paying
off your debts which all have already
done
to
baby step three and four and building an
emergency fund and then
talking about insurance talking about
investing and it's gonna lay it all out
there for you and i want you all to do
this together because you're going to
need somebody to walk alongside you and
she's going to need someone to walk
alongside her because you're going to be
learning this stuff for the first time
in your 50s
and it's going to alter your dream i'm
telling you right now it's going to
alter your dream but it's gonna be right
and it might be for the first time in 50
years
that you
sleep
all night okay
the first time you think about the
future and your heart doesn't start
racing on you okay yeah okay okay does
that sound good
it does it's pretty cool huh to sleep
yeah
yeah not worry if we get sick we're
gonna be bankrupt right yeah and that's
why i called because i
you know this is a lot of money but it's
all i have that's right so it's a lot of
money and it's not a lot of money all
the same time and marie one more step
for you i want you to go to
ramseysolutions.com click on trusted
pros i want you to get in touch with one
of our smart vester pros to teach you
what you need to do with this money when
it comes to investing i think this is
now your retirement nest egg this is not
land fund
yeah so that's what you need to do
appreciate the call we're rooting for
you that puts this hour of the ramsay
show in the books our thanks to james
child's producer kelly daniel and austin
screen of the phones back there and you
america and of course dr john doloni
we'll be back with you before you know
it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money and your mental health and your
relationships and boundaries and all of
the things that concern you and alien
i'm george campbell ramsey personality
joined today by the wheezing doctor john
delaney concern you and ale yes
i'm like a 1920s uh
keeper john welcome to the 21st century
i'd like to introduce you to a
microphone i think we need to get back
to the old times in some ways
our language the kids these days
my wife reminds me regularly that
she believes i was born in the wrong
century but i don't think i've ever said
well honey what ails you today
jesus oh we're having a good time give
us a call triple eight eight two five
five two two five john would love to
take your call instead of listening to
me but it is it is what it is
what ails you give us a shout what else
yeah we'll talk money life and uh jeff
was brave enough to call in all the way
from phoenix arizona jeff welcome to the
ramsay show
hi gentlemen how are you doing we are
doing great what ails you today how can
we help
i'm just kind of torn in between uh
buying a piece of property uh probably
be a retirement property
it's about sixty thousand dollars just
for the dirt
so i'm trying to figure out if it's
really kind of
the right thing to do the right
decision um
you know i've got a i don't have any i
don't have any bills i don't have a
mortgage i don't have any uh student
debt you know cars are paid off
house is worth about
the house is worth about 5.75
i've got a rental property that i would
probably sell that's worth about
about 250. i've got about 425 and a 401k
i've got about 35 000
liquid
um you know what was the liquid amount
of
stuff
35 000. so you would sell your rental
house to buy this dirt what's what's
special about this dirt what you would
you have a dream what's your dream
to put a house on it build a house on it
um it's in a
it's kind of where we want to retire
so there's not a whole lot of land left
there in the uh the subdivision um
so the prices are going up it's a for
sale by owner so
you know the property is
the asking price is 60 but the prices
around it
for the properties are about 90
92 000
so i can you know for sale by owner i
can get a pretty good deal i think
gotcha so what would this house cost
that you want to build on top of the
dirt
um it's about 225 a square foot so it
would probably be around 400 000
okay and you have a paid for primary
residence that's worth 575
yes
but you would keep the primary residence
and use this as a secondary property for
yourself
probably not
okay because you said you were going to
sell the rentals
yeah the rental we would sell gotcha
okay yeah i mean with that kind of money
you you've got the cash either way if
you sell one of these properties right
yes
how are you if i don't how old are you
jeff i'm i'll be 62 in december yeah so
what what's your timetable for building
this house your dream home and and
settling in
uh probably
two to three years okay
i mean i mean yeah you're debt-free
you've got a retirement um you don't
have a ton of money in retirement but
you've i mean you're a millionaire
you've got a million bucks in assets out
there and cash and if you want to sell
the house right now the market's hot and
hang on to that cash and
buy
dirt in your dream community
uh i mean that's what i would do if i'm
being honest with you that's what i
would do and you're still working jeff
yes what's your household income
about 110.
all right
well you've done really well um
aside from the the retirement account
which i think like john's saying if you
sold that primary residence
and kind of used that as part of the
nest egg and started investing some of
that or just sell the rental and cash
flow the the property could you do that
if you just sold the rental and cash
flowed the rest
uh yeah we probably could
i mean i like that plan because it sets
you up for retirement i just don't want
you to sink a whole bunch of money into
this property and you've got nothing in
retirement as you try to settle into
retirement right
right i think that the property i think
my
my first plan would be to
um invest in this this property this
dirt and
you know if i needed to sell it then i
could sell it and probably make some
money off of it sure
but you know
because the the price of the the uh the
dirt around it is significantly higher
than what i would be offering would be
buying the other property from one thing
i would check on that is make sure it's
been perked and all that it may be a
reason why it's it's 33 less expensive
than the dirt around it yeah dude i
don't have any problem with that if you
want to if that's where you all want to
end up you've worked really hard you're
a millionaire you're you're pretty close
just don't leverage yourself on this
decision yeah you do this thing in cash
man you got this way to go all right
amir joins us in toronto canada amir
welcome to the ramsey show
hi how are you we're doing great how can
we help
i'm just calling regarding a question in
a way it's two-parter but i'm currently
in university i'm 20 years old in my
third year
and over the past year and a half almost
two years i've been back at home because
it's called it and my classes and
everything have been online
but next term starting january my
classes uh will be in person and all
five courses that i'm planning on taking
will be in person
and i'm just
trying to decide if it would be
financially
better for me to move to
my the other city where my university is
or to continue to stay at home what's
the commute like right now
uh it's it's a drive and it's about an
hour and a half to two hours whoa and
you're there like five days a week
i don't exactly know my schedule but i
think it would be somewhere around
three or five days can you cash flow the
campus living
you won't take on any debt can you do
that
uh yes yes i can i have uh savings and
i have the money for it it's just it's a
high cost and i'm and the sort of degree
or
career that i'm pursuing is extremely
expensive so i'm trying to save and
budget as much as i can so here's what
i'll tell you
if you have the cash the research tells
me that students who live on campus
have higher academic they do better
on a host of metrics now that's not
universal that's just that's taking an
average of the students who live on
campus versus those who commute there's
something about meeting
classmates you all start businesses
together you form relationships together
you learn how to do this you learn how
to talk to your boss in the future all
kinds of data that suggests if you live
on campus there's some
some significant benefits
i'll also say if you have to
borrow to do that it is absolutely not
worth it because there's also psychology
of debt challenges and getting out and
the accelerated anxiety and depression
around i don't own my future a bank does
right so if you can cash flow this i
don't have any problem with that at all
man yeah
that's going to be a question man that
would be a great experience for you what
was your second question
we're running up against somebody
yeah uh it's the the second part is that
if i continue to stay at home i can
pay off my debt but if i move back to
school that people would be on pause
yeah well listen i don't want you to go
into more debt we can work on the debt
as soon as you graduate but it feels
like moving on campus is still the best
bet for you psychologically and
financially right now cash flow man you
got this this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
so let me ask you a question when you
think of a millionaire what kind of job
do you picture them having
is it some kind of high-powered
executive position like a vp or a ceo
well here's the thing only 15 percent of
millionaires actually have jobs like
that the reality is that the top five
careers for millionaires in america are
engineer accountant teacher manager and
attorney
that's just one of the surprising things
our team found out when we conducted the
largest study of millionaires ever done
they talked to thousands of millionaires
about who they are and how they achieve
that goal and our study also made it
clear that to become a millionaire
you've got to invest wisely and a big
part of that is getting good investing
advice
you need to work with an investing pro
who can walk with you and teach you
about the options that are right for you
our team recommends trustworthy vetted
investing pros from all over the country
that we call smart vester pros if you
want to get in touch with one in your
area just text the word invest to 33789
and start building wealth today that's
invest two three three seven eight nine
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined today by dr john deloni
and we are taking your calls triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number brian joins us in toronto
brian welcome to the ramsay show
hi guys thank you very much for having
me absolutely we're doing great how can
we help
uh i'm a recent graduate i'm 22 years
old and i graduated with my degree that
freehand people awesome i decided to
take the year off because i wanted to
pursue a master's of public health next
year but i wanted to be able to castle
and i felt that i needed to develop my
professional skills
way to go i had an internship in toronto
um and i've secured that internship and
when i thought there at the community
health center uh the first words out of
my supervisor's notes were you weren't
my first choice uh management made me
hire you
my question for you guys and it just
happened like two or three days ago
my question for you guys is what can i
do to salvage this relationship and make
it
to turn this experience into a mature
one that will help me realize my goal of
strengthening my cv and my professional
development
dude this is a this is a fun situation
john this is your super bowl so uh
i'm just saying i may have had that
happen to me a few times just saying i
think i've been the second or third
choice most of they ran through like 40
different personalities for they're like
god just hard to loan it then that's all
we got left so dude i've been there a
bunch brian um a couple of things i'd
recommend you do
first thing is
brush this off like jay-z said brush
your shoulders off dude you got to move
on from this okay
that in some ways that was somebody
trying to weaponize like radical honesty
and they were trying to make a power
play okay i'm not gonna give that a
second thought you know why because you
got the job
who cares who made you higher you got it
the second thing i'm gonna do is i'm
going to
reach out not because i'm trying to make
a move or this is a good political thing
no because i'm a person of dignity i'm
gonna say hey i'd love to take you to
coffee or can we set up some time and
here's something i do with all of my
bosses even at ramsey solutions i've
done this i did this with all of my
other bosses is i would ask
how do you like to get information are
you a lunch person a coffee person do
you not take lunches with different
people um how do you if there's a crisis
how do you want me to call you if
i want to be as hospitable and i want to
be the employee that helps them be
successful in their job
and i take notes and then i say great i
will go from there i've had bosses say i
don't do lunches i do coffees with
anybody who reports to me and i said
great and i've had somebody say i like
to do office in my office so if you'll
go pick it up i'd love to meet with you
once a month but i've had it all over
the place but you go first
and here's the third magic thing are you
ready this is gonna be the
brand new news for you so i want you to
hang on to your to your seat belts on
this one okay
do incredible work
and be fun
to be around
the the gold standard is do your job
real well and don't be an idiot
right if you do those two things and
they still don't like you then your boss
has a problem that you can't solve man
and
you're still going to leave this year or
the next year or whatever this ends up
turning into for you with some great
experience you're going to learn how to
navigate some of these wild political
systems and you're gonna get some great
leadership experience and you're not
gonna sacrifice your soul in the process
man okay can you do that will you just
go work real hard
and be a person of character
absolutely that helps a lot uh like i
said it just kind of caught me off guard
the first words out of your american
league
but so think about it this way thank you
two kids just showed up to the school
yard
and
one of them was like hey man my name is
is george and the other one just takes
his shirt off and flexes real big and
goes look at my muscles that's what just
happened to you and dude like it's like
cool muscles bro can we go play on the
slides that's what happened don't give
it a second thought just work really
hard be a person a character and you go
first with how can you serve your
supervisor man good for you
congratulations i love that out of a sea
of analogies you chose the shirt off
flexing john
there's so many that may have happened
to me as well well brian i i've been in
your shoes too i started at ramsey
solutions as an intern and while the
team was very loving there were people
who just went ah i don't buy it yeah
this guy's not for me not my cup of tea
and i had to prove them wrong not with a
chip on my shoulder but just going hey
i'm happy to be here i'm going to work
my tail off i want to be a guy that
people like to be around and here i am
eight years later yeah so that's the
best advice i can give is prove them
wrong and don't do it in a in a
revengeful way but just kind of like all
right that's cool man i'm 22 i get it
i'm a young buck don't have a lot of
experience
i'm here to get experience yeah so
uh three years from now he's probably
gonna be he's gonna go man that that's
that's my guy right there three years
from now his resume will be on your desk
and then you can say wow
yep good to see you yeah that's how it
is man prove them wrong i love it all
right nancy's in philadelphia nancy
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so much i have been trying to
find the answer this question hoping you
guys can help me my question is around
the long term care insurance portion of
it from my understanding that that
um world has changed quite drastically
um my husband and i are in our late 50s
and my husband was diagnosed with
parkinson's about a year ago
um we are current that's okay we're you
know it's all good god was gonna bring
us through all of that so i i feel very
super optimistic and super hopeful
um
so
my husband was laid off during
coronavirus and for the coveted stuff
he's still not got another job i was
laid off for my job
but i'm looking for a new job we have
zero debt the only thing we have left is
um our mortgage to pay off which i'm
going to do with gazelle like intensity
in three years get get back on um but
we're about 1.5 million and my question
is um worth and my question is do i need
long-term health care because i'm that's
what i'm looking at for him
and i don't know what to do at this
point
have you looked into what it would cost
for long-term care yes it's like fifteen
thousand dollars a day if he is you know
whether you know if we can't take him
care of him at all anymore you're saying
that it would pay out or what what does
it cost you what are the premiums every
year oh right okay so from what we've
we've been through the um
medical things we haven't been able we
haven't gotten it back whether first of
all if they will even
cover him there is nothing that i can
find long-term care that will take us at
the moment
um there's the hybrid plans which i know
dave is like a big node for the whole
term life and the hybrid plants are
super expensive like it's 20 for just
for me it would be 20 000
um a year and that would be for like 10
years but i'm not doing that i'd rather
take that 20 000 and put it into
investments and let that grow
so i just didn't know for on his side
what what i would do what i need to do
for him yeah i'll let george answer the
actual there's
where to get it and what age and all
that i think you're going to have some
trouble getting long-term care with a
with that diagnosis diagnosis
would be my guess unless you found
somebody and it would be incredibly
expensive if you do find it yeah there's
two options here you either self-insure
and use your own money or you pay for
this exorbitant premium and the only
time that we would consider buying that
hybrid policy is if you don't qualify
for the traditional long-term care so
while it's not ideal if it's what you
can get and that makes more sense than
you having to foot the bill and wipe
your retirement account out
i think it's worth looking into so if
i'm you i'm jumping onto
ramseysolutions.com click on trusted
pros and talk to one of our long-term
care insurance trusted pros out there in
your area they can walk you through all
of your options and help you make an
educated decision but i'm so sorry
you're walking through this that's such
a tough thing dude man he is lucky to
have you running point for the rest of
y'all's time together good for you well
nancy thanks for the call this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print and entree leadership
podcast both podcasts you can find on
the ramsey network i'm joined today by
dr john delony you can also find his
show the dr john delaney show on the
ramsey network and you have been
cranking out some shows john i see you
in the studio next door taking people's
calls helping people and then we put it
out there for the world to consume and
hopefully they get something out of it
yeah it's been wild man and what about
yours your you're the fine prince
crushing dude thank you it's been fun we
are we're trying to uncover all of the
the money traps out there and it turns
out there's a lot we're like we'll have
to save that one for season two we got
too much on the plate to try to uncover
now we just released an episode all
about bankruptcy is bankruptcy a quick
fix for struggling americans is there a
bankruptcy tsunami on the way
i talked to some experts in this field
we hear some real stories of people who
are on the brink it was fascinating
stuff i learned so much you can go check
that out on the fine print podcast feed
some really good stuff there some things
that are hard to hear and we try to
bring some levity to it i did my best
michael scott impression in the office
where he declares bankruptcy that's one
of my favorite tv moments of my entire
life it's gold like i try to keep track
of the hardest i've ever laughed and
that's in the top ten wow yeah
so go go listen just for that there's
also a dashboard confessional reference
in the podcast so i sneak a lot of
things in there just to make it fun for
me john but we're having
i mean i'm just looking at these topics
man you cover hard stuff like yeah
taxed off the true cost of credit card
rewards i only use them for the points
george makes me feel so don't rile me up
john not now
bulletproof your money for the next
pandemic there won't be a next pin there
for sure will be sorry guys man by now
pay later you know what's super cool
buying a 20 t-shirt on payments john
they now you can do buy now pay later
i'm not joking on pizza
you can put a pizza on payments well
it's just like putting it on a credit
card right yeah but this is worse
it's because of the mentality around it
of you know what why pay fifteen dollars
for pizza today when i can pay four
dollars for the next four months
what are we doing here man wow it's
crazy stuff bitcoin solves all of our
problems credit scores oh so good
student loans are back and bankruptcy
yikes
yeah man we're not even done we're not
even done in fact you are on our next
episode on holiday spending and if
you've been seeing the headlines the
supply chain is basically saying like
hey you're too late for holiday shopping
it's too late the pumpkins just came out
and you're already too late for
christmas so a lot of good stuff coming
your way we're doing one on diy
investing this year you get high fives
yep high fives kids well i relate it to
the jingle all the way with arnold
schwarzenegger and sinbad fighting over
the turbo man action figure on christmas
eve and it's the best analogy i can
think of i wish it was that fun that's
how dark the holiday season has come
that we're back to schwarzenegger and
sinbad we're back baby 1996 jingle all
the way so it's a lot of fun we're
having a good time helping people
understand that if you follow the trends
you will fall for the traps right do it
old school do a grandma's way that's
what this show's all about and you can
just operate outside of the system
buck the trends man that's what i'm all
about and i know you are too you know
what i love i don't like bucking this i
like sleeping at night
i like that my christmas shopping is
already done because they were telling
us about supply chain issues a year ago
and so me and my wife were like hey why
don't we go ahead and take care of some
of that life hack christmas a year ahead
of time it's not even a life hack it's
just like a math problem or a supply
chain i mean yeah some of this is like
oh
wait what am wait a minute halloween's
five day god well john people are they
they can't think that far ahead because
they have so much going on in their life
so much anxiety so much debt payments
thing to keep up with social things and
they can't even think about what's going
on this weekend yeah and so we've got to
get people to think ahead let's be
intentional man and that's what that's
what we do is all about so we're happy
to take your call it's a free one triple
eight eight two five
five and check out dr john dolone on the
next episode on holiday spending you
help us create some boundaries with
family around the holidays
super helpful stuff that is one of the
biggest things to face so a lot of good
stuff happening around here at ramsey
solutions we're going to tom in miami
florida tom welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys how you doing doing great how
can we help
so
i uh i know the
father husband inside me what i want to
do i just need some guidance long story
short i have a uh
2021 chevy suburban
that is um
almost paid off i have probably about
10 grand on it
i could turn around and sell it given
the used car market
for about 70. and
given the financial situation of our
family it would really help with
i haven't done a very good job
uh leading our family financially um
we're we're getting better
but um
you know it would put us and that's the
only debt that we have is that as the
rest of the vehicle
i'm i've been talking to my wife about
selling it and that'll give us a fully
funded emergency fund i'm severely
behind on retirement to the point of i
haven't started yet i'm 37 years old um
and with the scope of
the economy and everything and just with
you know everything going on
i feel like uh you know it's my duty
that
i gotta i gotta get this turned around
somehow my wife loves the car granted i
mean it's it's a beautiful vehicle
but we have three kids a two-year-old a
four-year-old
almost six-year-old and i can imagine
now i'm neurotic about it it's causing
me a lot of stress
that the car is going to get destroyed
and the value's not going to be in it
and so i'm just i don't know what to do
that's my question well number one dude
um
i this is this is one of the this is
this
i've taken a few brave calls today we
recorded several episodes of my show
earlier today and i talked to a brave
man and
you two are also brave
you're brave for looking
at one scary place and that's the mirror
and saying
um i need to make some changes i got
three little ones and i just i'm looking
at the news and the world's changing and
i gotta do i gotta do better dude i
wanna high-five you i'd hug you if you
were here i'm proud of you man that's a
hard place to start is in the mirror so
good for you
number two it sounds like you've crushed
a whole bunch of other debt is that
right
yeah we've we've done well we
we actually we bought a house in 2015
and we were very fortunate to accrue a
lot of equity in it
um
hey i want to stop you real quick you
know what you're really you're really
good at
when things are bad
you take the blame
and when things go well yeah you say we
or you say we just got really lucky on
this one i suck but we got lucky i want
you to own the good and the bad okay
yeah yeah is that a fair trade
yep okay so let's start owning the good
stuff so you bought a house in 2015 the
market appreciated you made a great
purchase and then what
uh we moved into a brand new home which
were blast beyond belief um
you know and
yeah i mean we've we've done some
upgrade you know we had to put a fence
around it you know so the kids weren't
flying the neighbors pond and you know
but we we you know we depleted pretty
much a lot of the equity with the down
payment of the home and you know all the
other stuff that we had to do to it and
you cash flow
yeah okay yeah
so to get to your question um
i don't have a love affair with cars
george i know you do so maybe you're i'm
just kidding you don't either me and
john both drive trash cars that are
worth a tenth of what that suburban so
if it's me
yes i'm with you i'd sell that car i
would go buy a great highlander
something that i could tote three kids
around in that also i could grow with
for the next decade and then i'm setting
everybody up
the other side of this conversation is
less about my wife loves the car
that that that's okay those
disagreements happen throughout
marriages all time
i'm more concerned that i don't know
that she's heard your heart yet does she
know that you are scared
um yeah
of
okay here's what i want you to do
i i have a tendency a lot of my friends
have a tendency to have these
conversations and their math problems
look at this we could sell this pay off
this buy this and be done with this
i want you to sit down when you take
your wife out for a meal and i want you
to look her across the table and say i'm
scared about our financial situation i'm
ashamed of how i've how i've led us here
and i want you and me to be together in
this making the next steps and i want to
sell this car and it's going to bring me
peace will you join me with this
[Music]
so
[Music]
the housing market is hot and your house
could be worth a lot more today than it
was when you bought it that means your
old insurance policy might not give you
enough coverage anymore and what's the
point of paying for insurance that won't
swing the cost to repair or rebuild your
home now some policies will
automatically raise your coverage to
cover rising home prices or material
costs but not all of them if your home's
value has gone up or it's been over a
year since you checked your homeowner's
policy you need to talk to one of our
endorsed local providers these
independent agents will compare multiple
policies to find the best coverage for
your home in your budget that's why they
are ramsay trusted because they'll put
you first period text the word home to
33789 to talk with a trusted home
insurance pro today that's home to three
three seven eight nine i'm george
campbell ramsey personality joined today
by dr john delony and it's a free call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five celeste joins us in phoenix arizona
celeste welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much absolutely how can
john and i help
so
my husband and i recently crossed kind
of a big financial milestone that we're
excited about but also now have a whole
new set of questions that we're trying
to figure out
in short we're trying to determine
whether it might make sense
to press pause on our retirement savings
for one year
so that we can instead front load our
daughter's 529
um for college savings
so you you got through baby step three
this fully funded emergency fund and
then you went oh gosh our daughter's
about to go to school and we haven't
saved
should we stop investing for retirement
the situ
i'm sorry to enroll too the situation is
a little different than that so first
she's three so we have some time oh good
um i thought she was like 17. yeah
no
and and we've we have been saving we
have about 25 000 in her retirement i'm
sorry in her fort 529 account
um you're doing great we've
yeah what makes you think you're not on
track
um
i think when when i started doing the
math and looking at calculators we got
to the point that i kind of realized
every dollar we put in now
will be worth like two
when she's in high school
and we're trying to think about whether
theoretically you might be looking to
retire around the same time that she
starts college so we're trying to figure
out if
front loading you know putting putting
more into her 529 now so that we might
not have to put as much in later would
put us in a stronger position just from
an expense perspective when she's in
college
well i'll say i don't want you to pause
investing i think you guys are doing
great
this is not a dire situation i mean
she's got 15 years before she's even
going to explore these college options
you already have 25 000 saved it sounds
like you're gonna have well over six
figures as this money grows over the
next 15 years is that right
we hope so um i think you know we're
also concerned about these crazy
inflation rates for college specifically
you know it looks like it's been well
over five percent over the last few
years but it it it makes me feel calmer
to hear you well i don't want you losing
sleep at night over inflation because
your daughter is going to have a great
head on her shoulders and she's going to
focus on what college she can afford 15
years from now
and there's gonna be options out there i
lived in that world i am
i'll just tell you i have an
eleven-year-old and a six-year-old and
i'm not front loading mine
um the
the year over year five percent seven
percent three and a half percent tuition
hikes that have been going on for the
last 25 or 30 years cannot continue
this college will be a million dollar i
mean it won't be a practical investment
so
i would not get
over out of your skis don't overthink it
can i just have you guys been doing this
for a long time you all been running and
running and running for a season
yeah pretty hard and you know i
mentioned at the beginning we have sort
of a milestone that we've crossed which
is we've kind of looked up and just
realized we we've got almost 1.2 million
in our
retirement account incredible part of
what's driving it too thank you yeah we
we feel really good about that and
honestly it just it just kind of
happened without our even realizing sure
well y'all are doing all the right
things and can so here's what i want to
shift your perspective
you you know have you heard of dave talk
about gazelle intensity
a gazelle is running from a lion for its
life
and that's how he wants people to attack
that he wants people to get
off that system like your life depends
on it
you can run into some problems
psychologically spiritually physically
if you continue running like that for
the rest of your life
and you guys crossed a
magic milestone and it's not magic you
worked your butts off and you got here
that way
i want y'all to stop for a minute you're
not running for your lives anymore
and i want you to breathe and have peace
and i want you to enjoy this little girl
i want you to do your regular investing
y'all are millionaires i want you to
live your life debt-free and i want you
to
put
the normal amount of money in this 529
understanding that either college is
gonna be a million dollars and they're
gonna have to figure something else out
or the colleges are gonna have to
re-regulate themselves which i think is
what's gonna happen
and y'all guys are doing a great job
you're doing a great job and you don't
have to run for your life anymore
thanks for that are you still there okay
there you are you're so taken aback
yeah just just processing some people
myself included get so obsessed with
sprinting and sprinting that we
are going to get to the end of our lives
and have a great retirement we're going
to realize we missed it
and that's why dave's so intentional
about baby steps four five and six which
is make sure you live too right be
intentional about your life but make
sure you're living too y'all aren't
running for your lives anymore you're
just not celeste how old are you two
uh 43
you're 43
and you are millionaires
you are doing amazing yeah
congratulations and you have a
three-year-old that you already have 25
000 saved for for college we have people
calling in that are way older with kids
way older who are a lot less freaked out
than you are so i just want to affirm
that you guys are doing so so well and
like john said take a breather when's
the last time you guys did something fun
for yourselves
oh i mean we're pretty good about that
good i just want to make sure because i
know it can be so hard when you're just
running a gun and to go no no this money
could be used over here we could fund
the college if we don't go on vacation
this year and this is a marathon and you
guys are doing great you're going to
retire with multiple millions of dollars
if you just keep following the baby
steps like you've been doing keep
investing the 15 percent build up the
529 do you guys have a paid for uh
property or are you working on the
mortgage after this
no we we have not paid off our mortgage
yet so that'll be
that'll be next great so i want you to
keep the other goals in mind too it's
it's not all about funding college we
love to say that there's a hundred
percent chance you will retire there's a
50 50 chance your daughter goes to
college and so we want to make sure that
you're taken care of first you've got
the mask on before
you help your daughter out and you're
already doing that you're going to pay
off the mortgage uh probably the next
few years at this point based on how
well you guys are doing what's your
household income
uh about this year it'll be about 250.
250. oh my gosh i'm not worried about
your daughter going to college debt-free
i mean you could cash flow this at this
point right just out of your budget if
you needed to um so you guys are doing
great and in 15 years guess what you're
gonna have a paid for house if you're
doing at the ramsey way
and you're not going to let your
daughter go to college with student
loans and she's going to be raised up in
that house with amazing parents who have
worked so hard to leave a different
legacy for her
that's the plan fingers crossed no you
don't need fingers crossed you're there
that's what people do when they're
hoping you don't need to hope
let me say this in a way hopefully you
can understand you're a millionaire
a millionaire and on average return
which we know things are like shaking a
snow globe every seven years it doubles
so if you're 1.2 then that's
2.4 and that's 4.8 million and that's
just when your daughter decides to go to
college y'all are okay
you're more than okay you're kicking but
at that at 4.8 in a paid for house
you'll be able to cashflow college and
retire and do whatever you want to
congratulations you're crushing it so
proud of you way to go celeste that puts
this hour of the ramsey show in the
books our thanks to producer james
childs austin selby handling all of the
phone screening today kelly daniels uh
acting associate producer i guess in the
back there and dr john deloney thanks
for being a great co-pilot on this wild
ride in you america for listening in we
can't do this without you we're thankful
for you checking out the show today it's
free call triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'll be back with you
before you know it
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money and your relationships and your
whatever i'm george campbell ramsey
personality joined today by dr john
deloney host of the dr john deloney show
john how long did it take to come up
with that name
the doctor probably too many hours the
amount of hours is embarrassing and we
don't even talk about it anymore
i had some cool like names for the show
after old heavy metal bands that they
didn't go anywhere it was a lot of
discussion didn't uh didn't really go
anywhere it's fine it's a solid name
yeah it's good strong hey but give us a
call triple eight eight two five five
two two five we're talking about
everything and hey we got a lobby full
of smart vester pros from all over the
country so good to see you wave
everybody it's great to see you they're
like kids in a candy shop right now
wandering around here it's so great they
are pumped up my kids in a cookie store
because they're actually our cookies out
there but it's good to see everybody
that's a good thing to to note that we
do have free cookies free mugs free
coffees all the combinations that's
right we love it just south of nashville
all right open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
zak kicks off this hour in huntington
west virginia zach welcome to the ramsay
show
hello hey how can we help
okay yeah so i'm calling because um
right now i'm pursuing
several pastorate positions
and these positions they come with uh
personages uh you know the house on the
on the church
um
and i was wanting to know what you
thought my wife is thinking that we
should just use a
housing allowance and buy a house
wherever we're at
but
i'm not so sure about that because if i
can get the personage it'll
it'll come with utilities paid and i
won't have to worry about any financial
decisions but my wife thinks that it's
it's not secure enough that it fall
right out underneath of us so i was
wanting to know
if you thought that i should
just go if we should just go for the
parsonage you know of the free house
with the utilities paid and you know all
that the stuff that comes with it so i
was just curious what you guys thought
about that
i i'll give you my perspective george
you hop in here too um
first thing is give me a picture of your
of your total financial picture
so well right now i'm a teacher but if i
take this i
will
i will uh
you know be a full-time pastor um
i owe about
50 000
okay
what kind of debt is that
it's student loans from uh seminary okay
um and what's this what's this pastor
position going to pay you
about 40 000. okay 40 000 plus a house
plus a house okay with no utilities
right right so they pay all your your
expenses when it comes to housing yes
okay so
you have a
picture of a house where y'all are gonna
crash
and your wife has a picture of a home
where you don't crash it's where you
live
in a season when my wife and i owed six
figures she's a
a doctor too we have a bajillion degrees
in our house too much too many degrees
in our house
we sold our home and we moved into a
residence hall apartment at a university
where i worked and we were faculty and
residents and we did that for a year
and i took on two extra jobs and she
was a rock star professor
and we paid off a whole bunch of money
and we had about a year that we could do
that
and so if i'm you i would sit down and
say
i dug us into a hole
50 000 in seminary loans and this is a
way to clear that up in 18 months or so
and i would let her know hey our plan is
to become debt free we're gonna let's
live in this personage and we're gonna
have no bills we have no electric no
internet no nothing
and we are as a family we're gonna suck
this up for 18 months or 24 months max
tell your bosses at the church we're
going to do this and then we're going to
expect the housing allowance on the back
end
and then you'll go buy yourselves a
place
but that's what i would do and that way
you can sit down and say hey we can
crash for a destination and in our home
me and my wife and my my son we made
those little chains that you make out of
construction paper i mean we set it up
this is short term for us we can do
anything for short term
and then we went and bought a house that
we could become a forever house right
not a forever house but a whole a home
that's what we said set up a home so
that's how i would approach it yeah i
love that mentality what's the housing
allowance if you took that
um you know
it varies from church to church you know
uh
but
about
like
1500 a month
okay and like john said if you could pay
off your debt stay at the parsonage and
then could you take that housing
allowance down the line
if you agreed to yeah
it would definitely cover you know stuff
because i'm in west virginia housing
prices are really low here there you go
you know yeah and so yeah you one of two
things is going to happen you're going
to be debt free you're going to have
accomplished something together you're
going to have sucked it up you're going
to be able to
um say look at what we did or
you're going to realize man living
partners is kind of awesome we call
somebody else when something's broken
and now that we are debt-free we can
just start socking away this this living
money and continue saving and saving and
saving at one point uh some point buy a
house with cash right but but again put
it put a short-term
lease on this deal i shouldn't say lease
i'm on the ramsey show put a short-term
leash
h and um then go from there and is your
wife going to be working at all zach
it's possible probably part time if so
she's an engineer so
okay that's great well i'm thinking if
she can come in and help with with this
shovel to get more income coming in and
you guys could clean up this debt even
faster and get her to that dream even
faster you clean up this debt you'll get
a down payment for a house get an
emergency fund and get out of there man
it's great good for you
thanks for thanks for the call zach way
to go man
interesting scenario with the parson
it's a fun word to say number one but
very interesting scenario where they're
paying for you basically you can live
here rent free and you experience
something like that in some of your
previous uh careers where they're paying
for this and so we've got to make a
financial decision what does this mean
for our future housing because i think
what the wife is seeing is hey we don't
own this we're not building towards
anything with them paying for our rent
well and
you don't feel secure because somebody
else owns your home right and we get
that call from renters a lot we get that
call from hey if i just sold my house
and moved in with my parents me and my
five kids and my wife moved in with my
parents for a season right
and i
i've done it and
for a season it was magical
and i say magical it was hard
but
in my case we learned that we could live
a lot smaller than we thought and every
house we've bought since then has been
actually small i mean we ended up
changing our whole trajectory of our
life we got rid of a bunch of stuff we
live a lot lighter and so we learned a
lot about ourselves and we paid off
everything and
um
it set us up for the next several
decades of my life because we we made a
hard decision there in the middle it was
not a two or three year decision right
it was hard with a little one and two
working people et cetera et cetera so
it's meant to catapult you through the
baby steps faster a short-term plan with
an exit strategy that's when it can be
applied we wrote down the plan we were
very clear and then we executed that
plan right brilliant that's the way to
do it get rid of the step man this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
for most homeowners being financially
ready to sell a house comes down to one
thing equity now equity is a jargony
word but all it means that your home is
worth more than what you owe the bank
for it and since home values have been
on the rise for the last several years
many folks have built up you guessed it
equity how much of the home you owe you
own so if you've been thinking about
selling your home the first step is to
figure out if equity is on your side
because you want to make money on the
sale of your home right if your equity
looks good it might be time to go ahead
and get your home on the market and
that's when you need to find an
experienced real estate agent to help
the right real estate agent does way
more than just schedule showings they
know how to accurately price your home
get it in front of hungry buyers and
help you navigate negotiations that way
you won't leave any money on the table
to connect with a top performing agent
check out our nationwide network of
endorsed local providers or elp agents
elps are the best real estate agents in
your area who've earned the right to be
ramsey trusted our agents are committed
to excellent service and to putting your
financial goals first
if you want to check them out just go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent you can find a trusted pro in your
area that's ramseysolutions.com
agent i'm george campbell host of the
fine print on and entre leadership
podcast joined today by dr john dolone
we're taking your calls triple eight
eight two five
five two two five lisa joins us in
minneapolis lisa welcome to the ramsey
show
hi thanks for having me absolutely how
can we help
yeah so i'm calling because um i'm
recently married and
um also recently graduated from law
school
congratulations huge a lot of life
changing thank you did you pass the bar
yes
i did yeah congrats i know they just
went out all over
congratulations yes they did thank you
appreciate it
um so i have um 60 000 of debt from law
school alone
yep how much from undergrad
none none excellent
yep my dad is a very
large proponent of
living debt free so my upbringing was
very much those structure around the
principles that um ramsay teaches so
very cool fortunate in that sense um but
my husband is still in grad school
and he has another
year and a half i'll graduate in
december of 2022.
um
and so my question for you guys is
should we
focus on paying off my debt now that you
know i mean granted the government isn't
requiring us to pay off anything right
now but i know we should be or should i
be
paying cash for the rest of his
schooling that he has
so the option is he goes into debt to
continue grad school or you start paying
off your loans
right
stop the bleeding yes
okay so pay his school
keep cash
yeah we want to minimize the damage here
going forward for your debt your debt
payments so as long can you cash flow
the rest of his school
yes great and as soon as he's out uh
does he have any debt so far
like 20 000 from
last trimester okay so that puts you
guys at about 80 grand total in debt and
that's all student loans
yep okay yes let's cash flow the rest of
his grad school and december 2022 he
graduates january 2023 it's game on
we're going gazelle intense with
hopefully amazing salaries what do you
think your uh combined salary will be at
that point
um probably over 200 it's hard to know
if um he'll be a chiropractor so it's
hard to know
sure as he's getting minneapolis it's
the most saturated market right now
so if you if you're making 200 and
you've got 80 dollars in debt that debt
is gone in under a year yeah yeah
okay
get it get it get it you're gonna take
cases on the side too he's gonna see
people in the garage they're gonna do
whatever you gotta do get that get rid
of that
and then you're basically a on a two and
a half year plan to be completely debt
free and then you're off to the races
and now you're making two three hundred
grand in a few years with no debt
and you guys are young how old are you
two
twenty three and twenty four oh yeah
dude congratulations this is what i like
to hear way to go lisa we're so proud of
you cheering you on as he finishes grad
school and you guys get this debt paid
off thanks for the call
nick joins us in annapolis maryland nick
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you
how can we help
so i a few weeks ago managed to screw my
car up pretty bad
i got it mostly fixed up but sounds
pretty bad so i'm not sure how long it
has left in it and i was looking at the
used car market and with everything so
inflated it feels like it might almost
be better just buy new so i was
wondering uh what i should do in my
situation
um
a couple of questions here so have you
taken it to get it looked at see about
fixing it
yeah i got a i got it fixed up a good
bit paid a good bit to do that and uh it
still
seems like it's probably going to be on
its last legs pretty soon what makes you
think that
um sound steering's pretty bad uh
it was already a little old and okay
kind of a beater to begin with okay
sometimes i have been guilty of in my
own life
i start finding problems with things
because i want to change
and especially after i get in a wreck i
have this feeling the car is not any
good anymore it's not safe anymore or
i'm just mad at it or i just paid a big
repair bill so i hate it
and so that's why i'm digging in like is
it are you done with the car are you
sick of it are you annoyed by it does it
make you mad up to me get in it because
you just had to spend 5 000 bucks to fix
it
or
is it really going to fall apart on you
um to answer your other question i think
it comes down to cash and what you how
long you're gonna hang under a car
um i'm
i'm i'm in the market to buy a used car
right now and i can say that out loud
because my wife doesn't listen to this
show and it's for her christmas present
and so i'm buying it early and i'll be
buying it the next couple of days
and i got cash and i'm planning on
buying a car that i'm going to drive
that we're going to drive as a family
for a long long time hopefully for a
decade or so and so the the
the higher price right now i it will
make itself up over the next decade i'm
not worried about that if you're gonna
buy a car and then sell it in two years
and sell it in two years and sell it two
years yeah it'd be a terrible time to
buy any kind of car right um what is
your
even though you think it's gonna be less
buying a new car well i don't know i
will say this i've heard some bananas
deals i haven't seen the numbers that
there's dealer incentives for getting
rid of new cars and then you can
actually walk in a dealer buy a new car
for cheaper than you can buy a used car
in some situations especially when it
comes to trucks and things i don't know
if that's true or not that's all
anecdotal what i would tell you is don't
do anything
on any sort of payment
do you have cash to go buy a car i need
to
i would definitely need to finance yeah
absolutely not hang on to your car man
so what's your what's your financial
picture how much money do you have in
cash in savings um
so in cash in my savings i think i have
about eight grand today um
okay uh 8 grand in 401k as well do you
have debt
um only the house oh just a house
okay yeah i bought a house a few months
ago right before graduation
so you don't have any debt except the
mortgage and you've got pretty much
you're basically kind of in this baby
step three maybe land around there is
this three to six months of expenses if
you add that up
yeah yeah definitely okay
so until that car actually goes to put
and it's not an emergency because we
kind of know this thing's on its way out
if i'm you i'm going to start to create
a sinking fund very quickly where i go
all right every month i'm going to throw
a few hundred bucks at least into a
separate savings account so that when
this card does go i'm ready to use
whatever money i have to buy whatever
car i can get for that amount of money
so it becomes a simple math equation
instead of well
i could get this 25 000 car new and it's
actually a good deal because use they go
for 26. that's just some backwards math
there and i don't want you financing
like john talked about so can you create
a sinking fund right now i mean you must
have a little bit of margin
in your baby steps now that you don't
have any debt
yeah um
i think i have about 2 000 a month that
doesn't go into like
so wiggle room you've got two grand are
you investing 15 into retirement before
that um right now i think it's doing
five percent uh i just got the
emergency fund back up so i need to
start doing the 15. yeah let's get that
investing up to 15. and uh do you have
kids
uh no i'm 22. okay so all the leftover
money after that 15
that's going into a car savings fund and
that's going to be my a1 is to get a car
that i can afford in cash that is your
next goal nick and in 10 months you got
20 000 in an account boom now you can go
buy yourself a used car that's not gonna
be fancy pants but it's gonna be safer
than when you got don't borrow money on
a depreciating asset don't be fancy
pants john said it best this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsey to get the best deal rules and
restrictions apply today's question
comes from caleb in scotland did i do
that right that was a pretty rough
accent but continue it wasn't great
it's fine
today's question comes from caleb
william wallace in scotland better says
my friends have gotten caught up in the
bitcoin market craze and are making a
lot of money trading
i know your company says it's not a
secure investment but i have to admit
i'm intrigued by the money they're
making
is it a good idea to put some of my
emergency fund in bitcoin and see how
fast i can grow my savings
george you are a bitcoin expert oh my
gosh john okay so we did an episode on
on the fine print all about bitcoin we
called it is bitcoin your ticket to
wealth could bitcoin be your ticket 12.
and what made me laugh at the end there
was to see how fast i can grow my
savings and in my head i thought you
mean to see how fast you can lose your
savings
that's that's the question i want you to
ask it's a risk problem john i know
you're you're big on this risk analysis
and what we found with bitcoin is that
we're not against bitcoin i'm not mad at
you if you want to put some money in
bitcoin but this is not your 15
retirement we're not banking on this
money to live off of now if you want to
do some fun money if you're debt-free
you're already investing you've got your
life taken care of you want to put some
fun money into bitcoin that's fine have
some fun with it but treat it like
entertainment because right now that's
what it is and so no it's not a good
idea to put your emergency fund in
bitcoin because guess what when there's
an emergency you're gonna need that
money and it needs to be liquid you need
to be able to pull that out of the
account and know it's going to be there
and with the drop of a dime or elon musk
saying something on saturday night live
your emergency fund could vanish
evaporates that frightens me so don't do
that man put it put your emergency fund
in a money market account and a high
yield savings account and keep it there
part for safety this is not where you
want to play with investing and for
those of you who want to use bitcoin as
a hedge
the dollar's all going down so we're
gonna have
please don't
please please
do just a rudimentary risk assessment on
how
how currency works don't do that don't
do that love yourself more than that
right
that's all i'm going to say that's it
that's it caleb thanks for the question
all the way across many ponds to
scotland yeah that's fun and we
either i wish you would have called in
and i could have heard that amazing
scottish accent all right open phones
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five allen is in houston
texas
home of the john d'alone welcome to the
ramsay show allen
hello gentlemen thank you for taking my
call alan what is tonight what is
tonight
you know something i'm actually out of
town right now oh boy oh alan i'm
guessing there's a big game john just
first game of the world series that the
astros are going to win but whatever go
ahead with your question
directly into the phone we had you nice
and clear there for a second yeah
okay so
[Music]
uh unfortunately
last month my father passed away oh man
i'm so sorry
yeah it's it's still hard
yeah absolutely man how do you pass away
cancer cancer i'm sorry
he
he fought the cancer for two years
when the doctors two years ago gave him
eight weeks to live
so he did good he's a warrior that's
right man
yeah dad was always a big time fighter
he
he did everything great he really did
it's awesome man so how can we help
today
so i stand to inherit between some
in the neighborhood of about five to six
hundred thousand okay
i have been a truck driver for 22 years
now
i could actually with that kind of money
buy my own truck and trailer
i would then stand to profit probably
about an extra
50 maybe 75 000 a year
up above what i'm making now
okay do you think that something like
that would be a good investment or just
putting
half a million dollars into a good
mutual fund and just let letting it do
its job down
well the the latter with you starting
your own business is a whole lot more
work i mean if you put 600 000 into a
good growth stock mutual fund and it
grows at 10 percent uh with a rate of
return that's 60 grand a year right
there which is what you said you'd be
making profit from the business now if
you want to start a business because
that's your heart and that's where your
passion lies then i think you start this
business uh what's your whole financial
picture look like do you have any debt
currently
uh about 28 000 on the car loan and
that's it okay and do you have a
mortgage
no i would like to eventually
buy a house okay so that was my question
is what are the what's the whole picture
so we can really look at your goals uh
holistically and go all right if a house
is your goal maybe we do that before we
start the business and get into the into
the trucking game so you're you're
renting right now
yes okay
if i'm you just this is just
brushing over it i'm gonna go all right
i'm paying off this debt a1
this 28 000 car loan is gone as soon as
you get this money followed by i'm gonna
pay cash for my first house and do that
as a way to honor my dad and the legacy
he left
well that's really important to me
actually in fact the
day i get the money um
taking 4 100 hours and pledging it to
his synagogue because that's what he
would want to do with it awesome yeah
because
his
wishes are most important right now
i just want to make them proud yeah yeah
um
when when do you expect to receive a
check
um it's going through probate right now
okay
um
so i already received about 150
from an inherited 401k
and the rest of it i added another 2 2
50
i would say probably before end of the
year
and then there's another 200 and change
invested in a building that me and my
brother now own outright okay so it
depends on when we sell that and all
that stuff so here's what i want you to
do
i want you to do nothing for six months
okay okay
and this is the advice that i was given
by the guy who
who trained me in crisis response and
it's been wisdom that i've passed on
over and over
nothing will make sense for six months
and you're gonna think it does one day
and it's not the next day you clearly
loved your old man he was an awesome guy
he left you a legacy he left you with
with you and your brother with financial
security
and you're gonna be grieving this and
letting this settle for a season
so i don't want you to sprint off and
say oh i got to go do this gotta go do
that i want to spend this money before
before you even have the check in your
hand i want that money to get to you if
it's coming in different investments you
may want to hang on to some of those
investments and not cash them out or you
may have to take um graduated
withdrawals from them depending on what
kind of accounts they are so clearly sit
with down with the smartvestor pro to
walk through what you've got
um but i want you to hang on to this for
six months dream a little bit think
about it a little bit and maybe i want
to get out of trucking all together or i
love what i do
man it's always been my dream like
george said i've wanted to have my own
business forever actually i just want to
buy a small house and settle down for a
season and become a local driver right
it's all those things um it just gives
you some space to grieve some space to
make some of those decisions does that
sound okay
yes it does awesome
very cool we'll be thinking about you
and your family praying for you and what
a cool legacy that your old man left huh
yes he did he did he
he did very well in life in business
but the most important thing too was his
family that's all that mattered was
family family family incredible
incredible thank you so much for the
call brother yeah thanks for sharing
that story that's awesome john i love to
hear situations like that where it's not
easy
but it makes it easier when you're not
left with a financial mess and instead
there's a financial blessing on the
other side yeah it's such a gift to be
able to say what do we want to do not
what do we have to do you've got options
that's one of the best legacies you can
leave
well so financial financial legacies are
great and so
i just imagine my kids sitting around
saying
man that guy loved me
i can't think of anything more
incredible wow love it very cool
awesome this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from 2nd
chronicles 15 7. but as for you
be strong and do not give up
for your work will be rewarded
christopher columbus said you can never
cross the ocean until you have the
courage to lose sight of the shore
amazing we had quotes back then john
who's writing these down 1450s yeah i'm
calling i don't know about that one he's
calling the bluff on columbus there
all righty well hey i'm george campbell
ramsey personality host of the fine
print podcast and entree leadership
podcast joined today by the amazing dr
john deloney host of the dr john dolone
show you can find all those shows on the
ramsay network
uh wherever you find podcasts all the
stuff john's show is on mondays
wednesdays fridays youtube podcast it's
everywhere that's right i can't get away
from it john i pull up my youtube and
it's all john dolone clips you've taken
over
yeah see i have this um
it's cool my job is every day i don't
get to just do a series like you do oh
that hurts that hurts john the amount of
work we put into our beautiful narrative
storytelling podcast let's do ten
episodes and call it good for the year
we're whittling away
with a little pick to make a perfectly
crafted 30-year podcast you found a
glitch in the matrix so congratulations
i have to show up every day to record my
show so it's cool man hurtful it's good
well uh it's been a fun ride guys me and
john clearly
uh two two hours and 40 minutes is our
limit together before john james is
about to pop in i actually don't show up
every day either so it's okay well the
way to avoid all of this is to go to the
phone lines john that's where we do our
best our best work and nina is on the
line in pensacola florida nina welcome
to the ramsay show
thank you for having me absolutely how
can john and i help
um i
have a question about trying to minimize
the accumulation of interest on my
um on my loans okay
on student loans
yes sir i have um i have federal student
loans i also have a private loan and
they have credit cards as well okay
so you want to minimize interest what
was the the thinking behind minimizing
interest just you you don't want to pay
more than you have to pay
yeah um ideally i would love to be able
to start paying it off but realistically
i'm in an intensive
nursing program right now and i don't
graduate until after the summer of next
year um so i wouldn't be able to start
working to start paying it off so um i
actually tried to
transfer my credit card debt um
to get zero apr for at least a year
try to get that interest down
i don't know about loan consolidation if
that would help
but try to get the interest down are you
continuing to take on debt as you finish
this program
i am
um
i am finding ways to pay for it um as
the semesters come i'm not taking any
more federal
loan that i'm not taking out any private
loans at the moment so what are you
taking out to pay for this
um the
money that's been coming in from covid
like um
the school's been sending me money for
clothes like um relief funds and then
everything that supplement my parents
have been helping me to cover it yeah
okay well the interest has been paused
with the student relief um extension
being in place until january 31st so
february 1st payments are back on
interest back on and so the best thing
you can do is pay off your loans while
you can right now but it sounds like you
don't have the cash flow to do that as
you continue to finish this program
so the only way to minimize interest on
your loans other than refinancing
getting a lower interest is to actually
pay off the debt as quickly as possible
and so that's why we recommend what's
called the debt snowball and it sounds
counterintuitive because what we say is
hey ignore the interest rate you're just
going to list the debts from smallest to
largest the balances you're going to pay
minimum payments on all of those debts
except for the smallest debt and on that
debt you're going to attack it with a
vengeance with everything you've got
with side job money any income you're
going to shave your expenses down to
bare bones and attack that debt because
once you do that you free up a payment
you are making on that debt and you use
that on the next debt and the next debt
and the next debt so that is truthfully
the best way to minimize interest is to
get rid of the debt as fast as possible
all right
since you're still in school and i do
know a special medical intensives
whether it's nursing or nurse
practitioners or you know you're in your
clinical rotations in med school
whatever
i understand those are those take up
your
your entire life you're working 10 to 12
hour 14 hour shifts and then you're
doing class work at night and then
you're starting up and doing that over
again your goal right now is to get
through school with no more debt
stop the bleeding okay put a put a plug
in that in that drain so the water
doesn't keep coming out
trying to fill up the drain doesn't
matter if i mean trying to fill up the
sink doesn't matter if the if it's just
all draining right back at the bottom so
stop the the drain stop the bleeding i'm
going to use as many metaphors i'm just
going to use 30 of them in this one a
lot of medical analysis
too many but stop that and then when you
get done with school you're gonna have
to make a commitment to yourself that
you're gonna do what george just said
put those debts in in order smallest to
largest and you're gonna start knocking
them off and you're not gonna buy a new
car you're not gonna go buy a new house
with your big nursing salary you're
gonna just spend that first year that
first two years getting out of debt and
you're gonna set yourself up for a
lifetime of
peace
okay good for you
thanks for the call nina we are going to
selena in salt lake city selena welcome
to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely how can john and i help
okay i just sold my house today earlier
today
congratulations
thank you thank you i'm currently i
moved out of state recently moved to
utah so i'm currently paying a higher
rent than my mortgage was but i sold my
house earlier today
and with the money i intend to pay off
all of my student loan debt which is
about thirty nine thousand
i love it i'm going to take five
thousand dollars add it to my emergency
fund which will bring that up to fifteen
thousand
and then i'll have forty thousand left
over
and so my question is what do i do with
that because i i don't have any car
payments credit card debt um i don't
have a mortgage
um and i don't want to just put it in a
bank and have it sit there
that's awesome so selling this house has
catapulted you from baby step one to
four pretty quickly yes where are you
gonna live
um currently i'm in oregon utah i moved
here for work from nebraska but are you
just renting an apartment
yes renting a town home uh the market
here is actually worse
for maybe a a
not very nice condo or townhome they run
about like four hundred thousand
wow we're out for out for outdated
condos that need all new flooring and on
a busy street and a corner spot so
that's
and it sounds like your next goal so you
you'll be investing 15 with this new job
i assume into retirement
i'm currently at 8 and that's another
thing because of my age i don't know if
you know if i should do the
traditional or the roth um i struggle
with that um
but currently i'm investing eight
percent into my how old does it work
i'm 42. okay i mean you can definitely
connect with a smartvestor pro in that
area to go hey what is my best bet based
on when i want to retire what my goals
are but on the money side once you've
got i would bump that up to 15
regardless of if it's in traditional
roth don't let that paralyze you in your
decision-making process but once you've
got that it sounds like your next goal
is to plant roots there and maybe get a
house
um not necessarily my daughter has two
years of high school left and so
i i just
there's a lot of uncertainties right now
so you might be moving again in a few
years i'm i'm i might be and so i'm
thinking whether it's
buy a house and you know either here
somewhere else i'd like to
possibly have that money
work for me somehow but i just don't
know where how you know do i open up my
own vanguard account
and do a you know standard s p do i dump
it in my retirement which you know what
i wouldn't be able to use later um
i think beyond the 15
it comes down to hey do i want to save
up for the down payment in the future
whether it's in salt lake city area or
elsewhere and you can park that money in
a high yield savings account and get a
half percent if it's going to be long
term if it's if you're talking three
four five plus years you could put it in
some index funds in vanguard you could
put it in some mutual funds to let it
grow at a higher rate
but if it's going to be short term i
wouldn't go investing into the market
yet especially if you don't know what
the next few years looks like
okay so short term would be if i'm not
going to
less than four or five years yeah one to
two years yeah if we're talking one to
two years that's too short for me to be
jumping in the market but if it's longer
than that if you're talking three to
five
you can park that in some index funds or
mutual funds and let that grow thanks so
much for the call it's been a fun hour
john our thanks to james child's
producer austin selby on the phone
screening kelly daniel associate
producer and you america thanks so much
for listening until next time spend
wisely save intentionally and give
generously this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you